thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story under oath and Under
Pressure Boris Johnson's defense against
accusations he lied to Parliament over
party Gates
complete nonsense I mean complete
nonsense I asked the relevant people
that they were Senior People they'd be
working very hard
family is now regretting their sacrifice
and demanding the former prime minister
resign as an MP
it's just
Soul destroying when you think about the
sacrifices that
we've made personally and the millions
of people made around the country
[Music]
also tonight the mystery trust which
helped prime minister Rishi sunak earn
more than 4 million pounds in three
years
as inflation rises again a surprise to
many driven by the increasing cost of
food and alcohol
33 people injured and a major incident
declared after a large ship tipped over
in Edinburgh
trust Prince William thanks British
troops in Poland for defending our
freedoms as he makes a surprise visit to
the Ukrainian border
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello good evening Boris Johnson swore
an oath hand on heart today that he did
not lie to MPS about parties at Downing
street during lockdown during more than
three hours of evidence the former prime
minister at times struggled to contain
his temper as he insisted emphatically
that drinks events were essential even
during the pandemic
but he refused to name the senior
officials who assured him that the
Gatherings had not broken the rules
but we'll hear from one grieving son
regretting his sacrifice in a moment but
let's begin with Boris Johnson's defense
our political editor Beth Rigby reports
today a day of parliamentary theater but
for all the drama above all this equest
for truth from a former prime minister
two o'clock came and time for Boris
Johnson to give Parliament and the
country his version of events under oath
the truthful truth and nothing but the
truth nearly four hours of questioning
trying to determine if he'd done just
that in Parliament back in December
2021. the guidance was
Mr Johnson today still Resolute I'm here
to say to you hand on heart that I did
not lie to the house when those
statements were made they were made in
good faith and on the basis of what I
honestly knew and believed at the time
except in he misled Parliament but
insisting it was a mistake not malicious
I apologize for inadvertently misleading
this house but to say that I did it
recklessly or deliberately is completely
untrue this committee though forensic
and when pressed on dates and detail the
form of PM quickly uncomfortable
this a gathering at the height of the
pandemic and then PM raising a glass and
thanking advisors who'd left their jobs
the photographs show a lack of social
distancing of two meters which was
required by the workplace guidance at
the time
could you accept that we're present at
this Gathering and that people were not
socially distanced while you were there
I thought it was essential for work
purposes November the 13th was a day in
which uh two senior officials in those
senior advisors in government
had left their jobs in very very
difficult and challenging circumstances
and
it was necessary
to steady the ship except the perfect
social distancing so Bernard is not
being observed but that does not mean
that what we were doing in my view is
incompatible with the guidance I don't
think we agree with your interpretation
of the guidance that's
a moment the former PM admitting social
distancing not always followed leading
to questions as to why he didn't correct
what he told MPS but I understand the
point you make there is confusion
between guidance and rules but yeah I
could have corrected the record at that
point but I I I I I I didn't think there
was any appreciable difference because
it was our job to follow the guidance as
much as to follow the rules and uh My
Views I've as I've said repeatedly to
the committee this afternoon is that I
believe we were following the guidance
Bend an instance is where he wasn't
socially distanced while also at times
seeking to pass blame onto those around
him if a minister cannot rely on the uh
advice of senior entrusted officials uh
when you have to get a huge amount of
business done okay then it would be
impossible for government to carry on
this the infamous bring your own booze
event an email sent out to staff
inviting them to gather in the garden of
number 10 in May 2020 published evidence
by the committee shows then director of
communications Lee Kane expressing
concern about her 200 odd person
invitation for drinks being somewhat of
a comms risk in the current environment
he was concerned about the Optics not
about the rules and he himself attended
the event and certainly no no concerns
will raise with me the event had been
within the rules why were you concerned
about the Optics
I I think I I can't say I think he was
concerned about the impression that
people might gain if they looked over uh
the Garden Wall some of the testis
moments came as Boris Johnson was
grilled over his repeated defense that
statements rules weren't breached were
based on assurances by trusted advisors
some might see your Reliance on the
purported assurances you received as and
forgive me as a deflection mechanism to
prevent having to answer questions about
your knowledge of these gatherings would
that not be a fair assessment no it
would be completely ridiculous
assessment you were there at the time so
it's a bit hard to understand what the
nature of an
oven it is when you have been there and
seen it with your own eyes I mean if if
I was going at 100 miles an hour and I
saw the speedometer saying 100 miles an
hour it would be a bit odd wouldn't it
if I said somebody assured me that I
wasn't today a highly uncomfortable
session for this former PM but no
smoking done
both sides stick into their guns the
committee pressing the former prime
minister on what it believed the
evidence pointed to that breaches of
rules and guidance would and should have
been obvious to him while Boris Johnson
insisted it really was not this sent a
standoff between a parliament trying to
assert its Authority in a former prime
minister trying to save his political
career and after hours of evidence the
outcome still very unclear
one thing is clear Mr Johnson will not
accept the findings of this inquiry if
it goes against him set in the scene for
another party gate Showdown both he and
the current PM could well do without the
standoff but that is beyond their
control Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster
so that was the evidence testy at times
now it's over to the Privileges
committee if the seven members find that
Boris Johnson intentionally or
recklessly misled MPS a sanction will be
recommended that could range from an
oral or written apology to a suspension
or expulsion from Parliament MPS will
vote on whether to accept the
recommendation and conservative MPS will
be given a free vote
if a suspension of more than 10 days is
voted through then a recall petition
will be triggered in Boris Johnson's
Uxbridge and South ruislip constituency
after that if more than 10 percent of
constituents that's around 6 700 people
sign the petition Boris Johnson will
face a by-election
whatever the outcome the former prime
minister's defense has enraged many who
lost family members during the pandemic
our people and politics correspondent
Nick Martin watched with a grieving son
it's been very hard watching Boris stage
his defense today
um it's it makes for very uncomfortable
viewing David garfinkel and his family
like millions of others stuck to the
rules during the pandemic while those
who made them broke them I just don't
understand why the prime minister of our
country needs to be assured by other
people whether or not rules were or
weren't being broken
[Laughter]
David's dad either shielded himself away
for most of the pandemic when lockdown
restrictions were eased he called covid
ended up in hospital his family couldn't
be by his side when he passed away
how does it feel watching this kind of
Defense being put forward by the former
prime minister given the context of
everything that you and your family have
been through
I think it's I think it's sickening it's
just
Soul destroying when you think about the
sacrifices that that we've made
personally in the the millions of people
made around the country
the the people running this country
didn't feel the same way about David is
now part of a support group made up of
those who lost loved ones to covid has
he said anything today that would that
would reassure you that that they that
they were doing this in good faith no
nothing nothing at all at the time when
people are dying in their thousands
every single day that you cannot
understand that you are breaking the
rules
it's just incomprehensible
is it your view that he's lying
yes I think he's
I think he's always been lying
this is one of the ways David remembers
his dad by inscribing his name on the
covert memorial wall on the South Bank
in London what makes this Memorial so
sobering so powerful is that it's
directly opposite the houses of
Parliament a daily reminder of just how
many people died during the pandemic in
the United Kingdom each heart along this
wall is a life lost and for those
families who made sacrifices who played
by the rules parties in Downing Street
rule breaking at the heart of government
is an affront to the memory of each
person who died during the pandemic
for the bereaved there are still more
questions than answers Nick Martin Sky
News
well to our political editor Beth Rigby
in Westminster now so more than three
hours of evidence Beth how effective was
Boris Johnson's defense
well and I think it's fair to say that
he was very well prepared and his
defense was multi-layered I think the
first point was that he almost didn't
accept the premise of the interrogation
insisting that guidance was followed to
the best of his ability in the workplace
in which he was working he also insisted
that he did rely on AIDS in order to
restore him that events were compliant
when he wasn't there and and I think
what he also did in that was he looked
to undermine the legitimacy of the
committee be it talking about some
Prejudice or remarks he said that the
chair Harmon made ahead of the hearing
and indeed questioning uh what evidence
was published but I think in terms of
where the committee were and some of the
dangers for him I think the first point
to say was in the round the questioning
was pretty hostile and and what I saw
was MP after MP incredulous if you like
when Boris Johnson uh insisted that it
was not obvious to him that guidance and
rules were not broken at events he
intended attended when it seemed that
the committee was clear it was I think
on a specific as well that the prime or
former prime minister there was an idea
about was it flimsy defense when he said
he relied on political aids for
reassurance that rules weren't broken
rather than officials or indeed lawyers
given that misleading the house is a
very serious matter and that might lead
the MPS to conclude that this somehow
was indeed a reckless misleading of the
house I think in the round I would not
be surprised if the MPS come out with
some sort of sanctioning for Boris
Johnson but that's unclear that decision
is weeks away and it could be anything
from an apology asked for to a sanction
that could lead to a suspension of the
house for so long that it could
potentially trigger a recall petition in
his constituency which could mean that
he might face a by-election but we've
got a number of weeks to go before it's
decided I think what's fair to say is
that while Mr Johnson might want to put
partygate behind him Parliament
certainly isn't letting him yet
Beth thank you
well while Boris Johnson fought to save
his career the current occupant at
number 10 published a summary of His tax
return after months of political
pressure the documents showed that Rishi
sunak earned more than four million
pounds over three years mostly from a
us-based investment fund and paid over
432 000 pounds of the treasury in the
tax year to April 2022
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
has been analyzing the numbers
the Prime Minister on a Christmas visit
to a soup kitchen in the middle of a
cost of living crisis eager to show that
he has the common touch
but Rishi sunak's relationship with
money is far from common
the long-awaited release of his tax
returns show that this prime minister is
one of the super rich
this summary document shows the PM made
nearly 5 million pounds in the last
three years just over one million pounds
of this with income including 329 000
pounds last year from his salary as pm
and from shares the rest nearly 4
million pounds was the capital gains
generated on a us-based blind Trust
paying just over 1 million pounds in tax
on 4.8 million pounds of income means
his effective tax rate is just 22
percent capital gains more likely tax
than a salary
far away from a dramatic day in
Westminster the prime minister in Wales
purely a coincidence that his tax return
finally emerged with so many
distractions in Parliament well I
published my tax returns because I said
I would in the interest of transparency
and I'm glad to have done that now I
think ultimately what people are
interested in is what I'm going to do
for them experts say this document gives
us a glimpse of significant wealth it's
clearly a vast sum of money we don't
know exactly how much it is but it's
into the millions and it could be
anything from 5 to 15 to 20 million
pounds of wealth and that's a big number
from compared to what we've seen in past
prime ministers this confirms Rishi
sunak is independently wealthy but we
already knew that what we didn't know is
that so much of his wealth is bound up
in the United States rather than the
United Kingdom and the bulk of it comes
from an American Investment known as a
blind trust now Rishi sunac knows what
went into that trust when it was created
but we've got no right to know and what
generates his cash
for most Prime Ministers payday comes
after high office for this one it came
before samcoat Sky News Westminster
all those details of the prime
minister's earnings were published as
data showed that inflation jumped
unexpectedly to 10.4 last month it'll be
troubling news watch closely by the bank
of England which makes a decision on
interest rates tomorrow our business
correspondent Paul Kelso reports
it's as hot as a summer's day in the
greenhouses of the Lee Valley but the
Harvest been delayed in the salad bowl
of England so our energy bills went from
circus 700 000 pound per year to last
year's energy bills just under three
million maybe 2.9 Million Pound a year
just on gas
they should be picking tomatoes and
peppers here already but heating 22
Acres of Glass House through the coldest
months wasn't viable for Growers
squeezed by higher costs and fixed price
contracts from retailers
we will be looking at obviously Energy
prices to see when we finish the season
so if come
August Energy prices are starting to
rise we'll probably make a decision to
finish the season early again CPI
inflation Rose to 10.4 in February
defying expectations of a steady decline
from recent historic highs
Rising food prices were the biggest
driver increasing 18 and accounting for
fully two percent of total inflation
this increase in inflation has come as a
real surprise to economists and its food
for thought for the bank of England's it
meets to discuss interest rates I'll
have to balance tackling what's
happening in here raising rates to keep
inflation down with the risk of causing
more stress in the financial system the
hospitality industry is feeling it too
the George's part Pub part Community Hub
but it's squeezed by the competition for
scarce workers that's driving up poor
inflation as well as food and energy
prices it's really difficult to find
Reliable
cheerful happy motivated staff at the
costs that we can offer it's simple as
that we're working 24 7 without a wage
minimum wage going up next month for the
regulars it's not just the price of beer
going up I'm a pensioner
and without buying food or anything of
that nature if I don't work my overhead
my outgoings the more than my income
every time I go and do a wheelie shop
which I did today
it's
10 pounds 20 pounds whatever more for
just the basic stuff these figures
should end any cozy assumptions about
the path of inflation the campaign
against Rising costs just got more
complicated Paul Kelso Sky News
along with the cost of living crisis
streamlining post-brexit trade checks in
Northern Ireland has been a priority for
the Prime Minister today his new brexit
deal sailed through the House of Commons
in the end only eurosceptic MPS and the
dup voted against the Windsor agreement
29 votes altogether but over 100 others
abstained many of them conservatives as
Ali Fortescue reports are you worried
about rebellion Mr sunat he's a prime
minister determined to deliver to fix
the Northern Ireland problem
Mr Speaker The Windsor framework
represents a good deal for the people
and families in businesses of Northern
Ireland the Rishi sunax brexit deal was
today unpicked in the comments we have
not yet fully addressed this fundamental
problem which is the continued
application of EU law for the
manufacturing of all Goods in Northern
Ireland rejected by some on his own side
too I think there are things in the
Windsor framework that are damaging to
the United Kingdom damaging to the union
and would actually make situation worse
than the protocol the recommendation to
the ERG was that we should vote against
the S.I so that I think is what quite a
few of our members are going to do in a
few hours time the most powerful blow
though May well have been this
order order we will now suspend the city
the former prime minister leaving his
committee questions to vote against
Rishi sunak's brexit deal division clear
the lobby but in the end it was a
rebellion contained eyes to the right
515 the noza left 29. the eyes of it the
eyes of it alok
the numbers today really mattered 22
conservative MPS voted against the deal
there were also abstentions but
crucially the government did not have to
rely on labor votes and they see that as
a victory Boris voted for Theresa May's
Checkers deal
put forward the protocol and he couldn't
Vote for This Improvement I mean I
honestly perplexed and surprised that
they didn't feel that they could vote
for him but what we've done here that
I'm really proud of is we've reset the
relationship with the European Union and
with Ireland and that is going to give
us a new basis to have a better
partnership outside the EU there were
high-profile Rebels but this was a test
of Rishi sunak's Authority and he may
just have drawn a line under brexit Ali
faudsku's Sky News Westminster
a major incident was declared in Leaf in
Edinburgh today after 35 people were
injured when adopt ship toppled over
during high winds 23 people were
admitted to hospital some with serious
injuries as our Scotland correspondent
Connor get his reports
there is only one question looming over
these docs how did a 3 000 ton ship end
up like this a vessel left tipping
dislodged from its Holdings in Dry Dock
it was a day of high winds and high
drama this part of Edinburgh embroiled
in an emergency
the staff that had been on the vessel
shared with me their shock
the
complete disbelief that happened but
also the fact that they were amazed that
they'd actually got off that vessel as
walking wounded this major incident put
pressure on a e departments already
under strain officials say 33 people
were injured 21 of those were taken to
hospitals here in Edinburgh and
neighboring Fife 12 people were treated
at the scene
the MV petrol had been used for
specialist deep water searches but it's
claimed it's not been used in three
years covered creating what were
described as operational challenges yeah
it's very unusual for this sort of event
to happen the most serious Dry Dock
uh incident of the late was almost 20
years ago in Dubai obviously it has been
very windy in Edinburgh today
um so that cannot possibly be ruled out
this is an investigation Gathering Pace
questions are being asked as authorities
examine a vessel now detained as
evidence Connor Gillis Sky News
Edinburgh
now to the race to buy Manchester United
the two leading contenders have
reportedly now submitted improved offers
as the deadline for second round bids
past well our Sports correspondent Rob
Harris can tell us more so Rob who's in
The Running Man to buy the club and just
how big are the figures that are being
touted
well there are two known bids one is
from Shake Jason bin Hamad the katari
son of a former Qatari prime minister
involved in banking and Qatar the other
known one is from Sir Jim Ratcliffe The
Man Behind the petrochemicals giant
iniosa there is some conflicting
information tonight as the deadline
passed for second improved bids to be
submitted we had been led to believe by
Sheikh jassim's bid that they had
actually submitted at their bid but we
are getting a sense that actually there
might well have been an extension to
bidding so that's the sense from the Jim
Radcliffe side as well we're hearing
actually that this process could be
continuing for longer and there may well
be now an extended deadline for all
parties to be able to submit a new bid
for Manchester United the glazers
announced in November that they were
open to selling the club or to look for
fresh investment but there is no
pressure on the glazers to sell so there
is no rush for this process and if
United was to be sold well could well be
going for more than 5 billion pounds
certainly the glazers will want to make
a hefty profit on Manchester United
being one of the most attractive sports
brands in the world but as it stands now
a confusing situation after the supposed
second deadline for bids passed
thank you
a 17 year old youth has been found
guilty of murdering a school boy in
Huddersfield in Yorkshire last year
fifteen-year-old Kerry McLean was
stabbed to death when he was making his
way home from school last September
another 15 year old youth had already
admitted murder at a previous hearing
the man accusing Gwyneth Paltrow of
crashing into him in a ski accident has
disputed her counterclaim Terry
Sanderson is suing the Hollywood star
after she allegedly crashed into him
from behind leaving him unresponsive
with several broken ribs and brain
damage he disputes the actor's claim
that it was he who crashed into her
saying it was not plausible with the
types of injury he suffered the hearing
continues
Ukraine's president shared this video
saying it's a Russian missile slamming
into an apartment building in the
Southeast city of zapparesia but Moscow
appointed official for the Russian
occupied region claims the building was
hit instead by a Ukrainian air defense
missile he did not provide evidence
there's been no word on casualties
but across the border in Poland the
Prince of Wales thanked British troops
for defending our freedoms in a secret
visit to a military base Prince William
was just miles away from Ukraine when he
met troops and refugees a royal
correspondent Laura bundle reports
the Prince of Wales coming close to the
Ukrainian border and a secret visit to
jejov it's where many Western weapons
arrive before being moved into Ukraine
and these are the British troops based
there just a big thank you for what you
do on a day-to-day basis you're doing a
really important job out here and
defending our freedoms is really
important impromptu thanks from the
prince who praised the collaboration
between the British and their polish
counterparts this was a chance to meet
both units with Prince William warmly
welcomed by the Polish defense minister
and for your training yeah
the soldiers here are part of Poland's
territorial Defense Force delivering Aid
and assistance to Ukraine
the prince we're told also wanted to
shine a light on the refugee crisis and
so to Warsaw and to Center housing and
helping those who fled Poland has taken
in one and a half million ukrainians
including Natalia from Keith
she says it was a surprise but a
pleasure to host him in her room and
they spoke about her journey from
Ukraine into Poland
Prince William says the Polish people
have shown inspiring Humanity this visit
is more than a show of solidarity for
those supporting Ukraine it is also
sending a strong message to Russia and
pitching the Prince of Wales firmly
against Putin's Invasion this is Royal
soft power playing out on a hard Global
stage and the conversations about
Ukraine will continue when the prince
meets the president of Poland Laura
bundock Sky News in Warsaw